texas governor greg abbott ramping up
enforcement after 53 migrants are found
dead stuffed inside a tractor-trailer
the governor's calling for more action
and accountability from the white house
and our next guest agrees lieutenant
chris oliveiras from the texas
department of public safety joins us now
good morning to you lieutenant
good morning thanks for having me on
well thanks for coming on tell us about
these checkpoints and what the
governor's doing
well this is another example a clear
example what the status state of texas
is having to do to take on this
responsibility and secure the border
because the federal government fails to
secure the border and this has been
happening ever since last year when
governor abbott launched operation
longstar which is a border initiative
it's all state funded it's all state
resources state law enforcement national
guardsmen but what took place monday
this past monday in san antonio with 53
immigrants that were killed uh because
of a human smuggling event governor
abbott again launched another initiative
to crack down on these human smugglers
and we're seeing an increase in human
smuggling events across the southern
border uh where these human smugglers
are placing these immigrants in
dangerous situations by smuggling them
in commercial vehicles and trailers and
wooden crates in the trunks of cars and
of course now with the extreme heat in
south texas
unfortunately and tragically we're going
to continue seeing more events that took
place in san antonio so the whole
purpose of this initiative is to deploy
additional manpower state resources law
enforcement to actually crack down on
these commercial vehicles that may be
used for human smuggling some of these
trucks already have made it past the
checkpoints they made it past border
patrol checkpoints so our focus is is to
stop these vehicles inspect them and try
to prevent
any more mass casualties that we saw in
human smuggling events that turned
tragic like we saw in san antonio well
the vice president the border czar she
says that your governor governor abbott
is playing politics and then she also
blamed trump's policies for all of this
with remain in mexico they say that the
borders are closed but the lieutenant
governor in texas said if the borders
were closed people wouldn't be coming in
we saw the highest recorded number of
apprehensions last month 239
416. this just proves that the borders
are wide open right
that's correct so all these all this you
know these narratives and these
statements by operational control and
and the borders are closed that's that's
inaccurate that's that's false
information they're providing false
information to the american people we
know that for a fact the numbers the
data reflects that
just to put this in perspective for you
and for the viewers i mean in the year
2000 we had one single month where we
saw over 200 000 encounters one single
month in the year 2000 ever since 2021
and now to present there have been five
months where we we have seen over 200
000 encounters along the border and
june's already be jews already going to
be projected to encounter the same as
well over 200 000 encounters and over
445 000 got aways for this fiscal year
that's known godaway's individuals that
have made it across our borders that are
now into the interior we do not know
where they're at and where they are and
also fentanyl we're seeing record number
of fentanyl deaths which we have never
seen before in prior years but again
it's all go this all goes based on these
open border policies the federal
government has and they have they have
continued they have continuously have
made a negative impact on the american
people by not securing the border so the
state of texas again it's time to step
in and take action i know you all are
overworked and frustrated because you're
not getting much action from from
washington but thank you so much for
what you do you're working very hard we
appreciate it
thank you appreciate it you're welcome
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kill me and
i'm ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis